adams with a scottish
more moral philosopher is the spiritual
father of capitalism
it measures 17 76 was the first to recognize and describe the
basic principle of the free market economy
his main work the prosperity of
nations is still considered the bible
of capitalism and in fact
this book was based on the holy scriptures
for ten years the most translated
book on earth
the theory of the invisible hand by
smiths spread around the
world like wildfire and is still at the
heart of the capitalist market
model it measures generated the
magic formula of free play of
supply and demand
even more he  also provided the
philosophical-anthropological
justification for the capitalist mode of
production man is by
nature selfish and concerned with his
own interests
and it is precisely this natural disposition that the
market economy accommodates by giving each
of us the chance
to increase our prosperity and in the end be useful  t it all
by everyone working
to improve their own quality of life
, as if guided by an invisible
hand, perhaps even without wanting it,
they
also demand the well-being of the general public. there is
actually such a transformation of
selfish energy into
social prosperity. how
does one's market model
really work  letting the economy run free
is capitalism people have to have
the natural economic system the
book of adams 60 minutes explains
his astute theory and i
also tried to
answer the question what use is this
discovery to us today it is clear there was the
triumph of the model and
capitalism
and  one thing you have to know
top politicians business bosses know
adams miss by heart but basically
you have to say that every one of us should
know the market model of adams miss
and be familiar with its core ideas
because this mechanism of the
invisible hand is more than just that
theory it describes the heart chamber of the
capitalist world and it is important
that we know the basis of the
social order in which we
all live today and probably
as it looks like we will spend our whole lives